je suis le tenant adrien jeu vers des
écoles militaires de draguignan où je
suis actuellement en formation ici donc
c'est là le dernier module terrain dans
le cursus de formation
j'ai passé deux ans de formation avec un
parcours de scolarité classique pour
passer une licence et un parcours plus
militaire ou là on nous apprend on nous
entraîne au quotidien à
comprendre et acquiert les qualités d'un
chef de section ensuite je me spécialise
dans une école d'armes les écoles d'art
vous en avait partout laver à draguignan
pour la retirer pour l'infanterie et les
aussi à grignan saumur pour hakan
eriksson
cet exercice du ciad à 2022 permet de
finaliser leur formation avec des trucs
de manoeuvre au sol avec des moyens
aériens qui sont conséquents avec des
moyens de simulation qui sont réalistes
et tout ça permet l'enrichissement du
lieutenant et finalement la validation
de son année